[موسيقى]
لو رايت المصنع من الداخل داخلت نفسك في
اوروبا او في فرنسا النظام الالات كل شيء
كان رائعا
[موسيقى]
عندما انطلقت الثوره وتراكمت المشاكل وصل
احمد الجلودي
قبله كان هناك نرويجي لا اتذكر اسمه معروف
يعني يقول العمال والمدراء والمزودون انه
كان على علاقه مع
داعشات المرتزقه والارهابيين
فراس اطلس المساهم السوري في مصنع لافارج
بسوريا عمره 63 عاما قضى منها عشره اعوام
كلاجئ لا يتخفى كليا ولكنه يحتاط جيدا اذ
حكم عليه كل من تنظيم الدوله والنظام
السوري بالاعدام
ممن تخاف اكثر
من كثيرين
لا احد يملك قائمه كهذه
يضم مجموعه تشكيلات الجيش السوري الحر
والجهاديين وغيرهم ممن يتبعون دولا اجنبيه
او اطرافا سورية والتي نشطت ما بين 2011
و2019 في كل شبر من سوريا
وهذه اسماء التشكيلات لواء الخير كتائب
الصديق دير الزورليو السلطان مراد لواء
الشهيد احمد خلف لواء اولاد الكرامه لواء
شهداء ادلب لواء التحرير
يوسف العظمه كتائب فرسان ساحل
حتى داعش والنصره تتشكلان من مجموعات
عديده تحمل اسماء صغيره انها هنا هذه
ارقام هواتف نقاله وهنا العناوين
الالكترونيه وحسابات سكايب انه عمل
استخباراتي عميق من الصعوبات الحصول على
رسائل الكترونيه وامور كهذه لابد ان تكون
على الارض لتحصل على كل هذا طبعا لدي
اشخاص بسوريا حتى الان والا فكيف احصل على
معلومات
انهم يخبرونني يوميا بكافه المستجدات
مقرات داعش وجبه النصره
حاليا
المستاجر هاي داعش بس
من قدام الباب الرئيسي حاليا هذا الباب
داعش
[موسيقى]
بعد التفجيرات 2015 اتصل بي وقال لي هل
انت مستعد لابرام عقد كالذي يربطك
بالامريكيين قلت نعم بالطبع
فاتى برفقه عدد من الاشخاص لم يكن وحده
ناقشنا خلال يومين ونصف كل التفاصيل
تحدثنا عن المكلفين بجمع المعلومات في
ادلب ومنبج والرقه والحسكه ودير الزور في
مناطق شمال سوريا لقد دفع لنا مقابل كل
مهمه بما يشمل الرواتب الفريق وغير ذلك
لقد كان عقدا
[موسيقى]
بعد ست سنوات من التحقيق توصلت الشرطه
القضائيه الى ان مصنع لارج مكانه تنظيمات
المسلحه من الحصول على ما بين مليونين
وسبعه ملايين يورو تحرياتنا اكدت حدوث
معاملات ماليه اموال دفعها رجال فراسلاس
ورشا ودفعها زبائن المصنع واطنان من
الاسمنت تركت في سوريا في المحكمه سيتم
تحديد من من هؤلاء الرجال هم الاشرار ومن
هم الابطال حتى الان يفترض انهم ابرياء
[موسيقى]